-Alright, here's the first song
right now.
-♪ Alright, stop ♪
-♪ Oh, baby ♪
-♪ Collaborate and listen ♪
♪ Ice is back with a brand-new
invention ♪
-Oh, "Ice Ice Baby."
-♪ Something grabs a hold of me
tightly ♪
♪ Flows like a harpoon daily
and nightly ♪
♪ Will it stop?
Yo, I don't know ♪
♪ Turn off the lights ♪
-"Hit Me Baby" and then...
-♪ To the extreme I rock a mike
like a vandal ♪
♪ Light up a stage and wax
a chump like a candle ♪
♪ Dance, go rush the speaker
that booms ♪
-What's the other one?
Why am I forgetting?
Oh, my God, Blake,
do you know it?
-♪ Gonna hold you tightly ♪
-Aaaah!
-♪...do this all nightly ♪
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chime plays ]
Alright.
John and Kelly have buzzed in.
-Wait a minute! I didn't know --
You didn't tell me
I had to buzz in!
-It doesn't matter.
-You're the worst host ever!
You didn't say you got to buzz!
-We just started the show!
I'm gonna be the worst host
ever.
Here we go. They locked it in.
-It's so weird to me
that we knew
you should buzz in
and he didn't.
-Yeah. So surprising.
Let's see what we got here.
"Ice Ice Baby One More Time"!
That is correct!
-Yes!
-For 1,000 points.
-Please, guys, you have to --
Can you not show ours?
-Let's just see
what you typed in.
-Blake typed this.
-"Hit me baby in the face."
Now, Blake, I had a feeling --
-I only knew one song.
Did you know the other one?
-I did.
I just didn't understand --
-I knew one song.
-I saw you typing.
-"Hit me baby in the face."
-You are the worst partner ever.
-No, no!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-We just started.
We just started.
-Worst host. Worst partner.
[ Crowd booing ]
-Wow!
-And worst crowd!
[ Laughter ]
And worst crowd!
-What are you doing?!
-Whoa. He's playing up
the villain thing here.
-Here we go.
Here is the next one.
♪♪
-"California."
-"California Dreamin'." Right?
-♪ If you see a faded sign
on the side of the road ♪
♪ That says 15 miles to the ♪
-"Love Shack."
-♪ Love shack ♪
-♪ Love shack, yeah ♪
-Well, then it's not
"California Dreamin'."
Doesn't make sense.
-♪ I got me a car that's as big
as a whale ♪
-No, no, no, no!
That's not that song.
[ Chime plays ]
Oh, my God, Blake!
-♪ So hurry up and bring
that jukebox money ♪
-Oh, my God!
-This is going to be amazing!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chime plays ]
-You're amazing.
-Alright, you locked in first.
Let's see what you wrote down.
"California Love Shack."
Correct for 1,000 points!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-This is too easy!
-She said "California Dreamin'."
-No, I did not!
-Who said that? Me?
-You said that!
-Let me just see what you guys
wrote down just so we can --
[ Buzzer ]
This is like --
-BFF.
-What is that?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know, man.
We're warming up.
-This next one is pretty --
-"We're warming up."
-Don't, Kelly Clarkson.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to do
one more song,
and this is worth 5,000 points,
and I'm gonna see --
Can I try this one?
I'm gonna get in on this one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy's gonna sing.
♪♪
-Oh!
-"Cry Me a River."
♪♪
-Let's do it!
-♪ Right now,
I'm in a state of mind ♪
-Oh, my God.
-♪ I wanna be in
like all the time ♪
♪ Ain't got no tears
left to cry ♪
♪ So I'm pickin' it up,
pickin' it up ♪
♪ I'm lovin', I'm livin',
I'm pickin' it up ♪
♪ I just want you
to come with me ♪
-♪ Cry me a river ♪
-♪ We're on another mentality ♪
-♪ Ain't got no tears
left to cry ♪
♪ So I'm pickin' it up,
pickin' it up ♪
♪ I'm lovin', I'm livin',
I'm pickin' it up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, who buzzed in first?
It was Blake and Ariana.
-Oh, really?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I hope you guys got this one.
Let's see what you wrote down.
-I really hope.
-Survey says...
-"No Tears Left
to Cry Me a River."
Correct for 5,000 points!
You're back in the game.
-Wow.
-Let's just see
what you typed in.
It was very close.
-Except for the 1,000 you still
gave them, but it's fine.